it is time for drew's news your daily
bleep blue from the good news robot
i can't do the robot
you know who does the robot the best
leonardo dicaprio really the words of
paris hilton so
hot well with me at the desk is the
hottest man in town also my co-pilot
ross matthews
hi everybody hi
hi crew
i've never been able to do the robot and
when a guy
for me does the robot well i'm like
when they do that thing in the arm they
do this and it just swings like that
there's something so sexy about it
what does that say about you you find
the robot so hot well it's a human doing
the robot because i definitely don't
look at robots and get hot oh really
no no fortunately not as much as i
believe in animism which is i think what
animation comes from to believe
everything has a soul and i am one of
those weirdos who like the vcr would
flash and i'd be like there's a man in
there like having a panic attack just
saying sent me yeah
[Laughter]
you might be bonkers you know that yeah
well first up in the news we're starting
with the latest fashion trend this is so
fun the new york post says that people
are showing off their bagel pride with
deli core
god it never stops you guys local bagel
shops are pumping out custom merch so
you can wrap your favorite local deli in
style here's some examples pete davidson
is on trend here with uncle paulie's
the hat he is wearing that's a deli in
la and then fellow hottie jake
gyllenhaal teamed up with russ and
daughters for a limited locks a
sweatshirt and then coach and zaybarz
got together and they had a bagel bag
baby retailing at 550 dollars which
sounds like a lot of money but it's sold
out yeah you know it's not a lot of
money for a bagel bag but it is a lot of
dough
thank you
so stupid
i but i love that this wearing your
bagel pride is now a trend do you know
how long i've been doing it like this is
a bagel this is a bagel this is a bagel
i've been wearing it for years that's
where i was going with it too like i've
got 15 bagels on my body but they're
just not in the form of fashion i know
you you need a mac and cheese shirt
because that's your favorite
food ever right i actually went
backstage to do a quick change and i
passed by our test kitchen and there's
piles of boxes of macaroni and cheese
back there and i just grabbed when i was
like yeah i need one of these too guys
so i feel yeah raw seeds all right well
i need a bagel shirt you know my
favorite restaurant in the entire world
is chili's
anyone here ever had this the skillet
queso dip
so put that on a shirt girl i will wear
that i'll meet you with your mac and
cheese shirt well why
can you take me to a chili's for queso
skillet dip have you never had their
case of skeleton i haven't i would hello
drew barrymore i'm ross matthews and i'm
about to change your life
well we go on many dates so let's add
that to the list next one's chili's love
you i'll love you perfect all right now
i want jellies thanks a lot all right
next up more news do you all remember
this story went viral i think like in
the summer it was about a a singing
plumber who got discovered while working
at a record producer's bathroom did you
hear about this well yeah he was singing
the record producer heard him and now
the bbc reports the singing plumber kev
crane is getting his own movie about his
miraculous story yeah kevin's been
singing his entire life but it took that
one unlikely event to get him his first
record at the age of 50. and we have a
little taste of kev's tunes here's a
clip of an original song called you
don't have to live like this before we
listen it's important to mention that
kev used to absolutely kill it in a
depeche mode cover band oh that does
tell me a lot yeah and you can
definitely hear that inspo right here
take a listen
[Music]
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
um
i also heard a clip um of him covering
um a billy idol song
and he has really got a beautiful voice
he does and he's super smart because i i
feel like i can sing even though you
know um and i the fact that he like was
just humming at a record producer's
house very smart because if i was like a
male man who could sing and i knew that
you were a recognition i'd be like
here's your mail
you know what i mean hello he got that
record deal he's so sweet too i heard
that he said um like and i quote like i
can't believe this is my life and that
my dream came true which is just so
grateful and i always appreciate hearing
stuff totally and like how amazing that
he was discovered otherwise all this
singing talent from this plumber would
have just gone down the drain
i couldn't even get through that one um
i love you so much it just hurts
[Music]
you